hi this is a Sadashiva pie from science
mission we have today dr. or wager
professor of psychology and neuroscience
and cognitive sciences at the University
of Colorado with us so as of july 2019
he is joining the faculty of Dartmouth
College as a professor there so he is
received is a PhD from University of
Michigan in cognitive psychology in 2003
and served as an assistant and associate
professor at the Columbia University
from 2004 to 2009 since 2004 he has
directed the cognitive and affective
neuroscience lab a research lab devoted
to work on the neurophysiology of
affective processes paying emotion
stress empathy and how they are shaped
by cognitive and social influences dr.
Vega and his lab are also dedicated to
developing analysis methods for
functional neuroimaging and sharing
ideas tools and scientific data with the
scientific community and public so he
has also published more than hundred
peer-reviewed articles and he's in the
editorial board of several journals so
welcome dr. wager to science hangout
thank you everybody
hi tell me about your background
education a little bit about that yeah
so before I ended up in Michigan from a
PhD I majored in music uh-huh and I was
a music theory and Composition major
okay but I wasn't very good at music so
I graduated knowing that I wasn't going
to be a professional musician do that
and I really started thinking about what
is it that I want to contribute to the
world what am i interested in I've been
interested in scholarship and science
for a long time it's a good
fit for me I thought what's the coolest
thing ever to study and it's the brain
obviously so early on I had this
experience where I I didn't know what I
wanted to do and I really realized that
if I didn't choose something I wasn't
going to choose anything and nothing was
going to happen and then I just got
really excited about starting to study
the brain
so I took my music degree I learned to
work hard you know and music and ah I
learned to struggle not being that good
at things and then I applied that to
something that I think is a better fit
and started taking classes in
neuroscience and neural networks and in
cognitive psychology and you know the
rest is history essentially I really
felt like yeah that's a path sort of
opened up for me to be able to uh-huh do
this and I've pursued it ever since and
I love it okay yeah let's talk about a
little bit about your lab lab people and
also just give a little bit more a
description of your lab people and all
yeah I love my lab it's a terrific group
of people they'll get contributed
everything to the work that I'm going to
show you hard work you know I one thing
that I I like about the light it's a
experimental research lab we do a lot of
work with human brain imaging so we're
trying to devise tasks they capture
feeling states pain emotion stress
compassion empathy in people and then
try to understand what is it about the
brain systems that we can measure with
with fMRI mainly and other things that
that really capture that or that predict
that or create that response so there's
a lot of experimental design a lot of
cognitive psychology a lot of emotion
theory and effective theory some psycho
physiology and a lot of computation and
statistical principles and computational
principles and now uh you know machine
learning techniques and other things
that we're bringing to bear so it's very
diverse methodologically it's very
integrative and my lab has been very
diverse
I think geographically
as well we've had people in the lab at
one time from eight different countries
which has been really a lot of fun I
think people come in and they seem to
understand that it's really we're
working for a win-win situation you know
we're all promoting each other there's
tons of work to to to do and our success
depends on us being able to collectively
do it fast and well you know so I'm a
real believer that the whole is greater
than some of its parts
and I think people in my lab get that
and you know that makes me really happy
okay yeah like you have a long career
and you have interacted with many people
can you talk about your mentors because
which is crucial in the development of a
scientist so who has helped you
supported you over the years in getting
to where you are right now
yeah I think I mean many people have
inspired me and taught me something I
think so
you know I'll pick out a few people but
I think there's so many influenced me
and made me a better person and
scientist I kind of think thinking about
this question I think we kind of pick
and choose the things that we really
like and admire from different places
and different people so one you know one
person for me is my graduate advisor at
Smith he exemplified really a kind of
kindness but also combined with honesty
you know so we didn't like an idea we
didn't understand it you wouldn't hold
back you tell you what I really thought
and I think you always know where you
stand with him that's really important
and another thing I learned from him is
about keeping connected with old friends
you know we need passed away he had
people that he had known you know come
to see him before that and you know come
to his pressure up from from his
childhood you know and he it really kept
connected to the with default my other
co advisor John Genovese is sort of for
me exemplified that I you know being
focused and direct you know he wouldn't
pull any punches
if you
believe something or like something he
tells you yeah that gives you the you
know it communicates that we're strong
enough to handle criticism and then it
makes you better
mm-hmm no no I've had number of mentors
you know give me critical feedback or
tell me where I was going wrong and
that's really important
another one of my mentors is was from my
music days and undergraduate Murray now
she goes by Murray sureiy but she was a
flutist in Orchestra and really played
with the best you know some of the most
famous performers are in conductors and
she was conducting the orchestra at a
little College where everybody was kind
of like you know if not so so great and
sometimes she would look and she'd say
stop stop stop and then she would just
kind of smile and say let's play a lot
of you know forbearance and grace really
I call it grace but I also you know
think that she also taught me about the
pursuit of excellence and if you really
want to be excellent at something you
know there's a standard that you want to
aspire to and it's really much different
than what most people you know the
average person around you is is gonna
pursue right uh-huh
so really I think in music too and in
dance and other things like that people
really pursue these standards of
excellence right because it's on display
for the world you know to see Merle
Holloman is another person who would
taught me the same thing and dance and
and many other people really okay that's
good like I know you are busy with you
all your research grant interacting with
the students and all those things so how
do you spend your free time like what
are your hobbies and in case if at all
you do anything sometimes people don't
have time I understand that I'll tell
you what I used to do I like to say you
have time for two things and here is one
thing and family is one thing I think
yeah and you know I I really I gave up a
lot of
hobbies when I started graduate school
and really focused him but I do believe
in living a balanced life you know I
wasn't a lot of things before ceramics
making pottery sculpture music yoga
skiing tennis biking martial arts ballet
for a time lots of different sports a
lot of outdoor sports you know hiking
and camping and kayaking mm-hmm and now
I you know I spend time with the family
I work I run okay I do Twitter yeah I
try to get a roof like squash these days
no I think I try to keep some balance
but really a lot of focus on the family
yeah okay and now going back to the what
part so tell me something about some of
the stuff you are doing and eventually
you can go and present your work
basically yeah I mean we're doing a lot
of different things surrounding really
sort of two themes that complement each
other one theme is trying to develop
better models and measures of the brain
systems and how they are specifically
linked to things that we care about
measuring my pain or various kinds of
emotions or feelings of warmth and
empathy so do a lot of work on those
things so building measures and then
once you have the measures in the brain
then you can use those to understand
interventions so what kinds of factors
influence those things um you know does
a mindfulness intervention you know
intervention do something for you does
self-regulation or kind of trying to
sort of reframe things in your mind does
that actually help you and how and what
what does it do as you'll see we do a
lot of work giving people
possi bo medication so sham medications
because what we're doing is we're
manipulating their expectations and
their beliefs and understanding what are
the causal effects of those expectancies
and beliefs on outcomes that we care
about so a lot of this intervention
stuff is focused around this idea of
what does what can you do with your mind
with your thought with your especially
your use of conscious conceptual thought
that matters in terms of shaping that
the course of your life and your
outcomes okay yeah so you can present to
it work
do you have a chance sure I want you to
do it so on the talk I'm gonna give
today is about one of my really first
loves and research which is both effects
and it extends from some old work into
some new work that we're doing now I'm
going to share my screen hopefully you
can see it there there yeah you should
see Boulder Colorado uh-huh and where it
is on the earth as we zoom out um so
here we go just let you see it for those
of you who don't live in Colorado there
there we are in the world okay this is
the Ebers papyrus this is one of the
oldest known pharmacopoeias it documents
over 700 ancient medicines that were
entered in in Egypt in the surrounding
area and some of those things would be
familiar today so for example if you
have a headache
you might get a tincture of wormwood
which is related to present-day absinthe
and opium which is related to opiates of
course and some of these seem very
strange so if you were poisoned you
might get powdered emerald or Bezemer
stones which are undigested matter from
the intestines of animals and many other
treatments including human sweat feces
of humans and animals tapeworms and
other kinds of worms one of my favorites
is usnea
moss scraped from the skull of a hung
criminal much later in you know Europe
during the Enlightenment period and also
much later powdered Egyptian mummy
itself and I think the first thing to
note is all of these things are probably
not helpful at all they're really all
placebos and many of them are harmful I
mean we would never
and today but these were given to the
rich as well as the poor so this was
king charles when you have an illness
was treated with a pint of blood
extracted from his arm and his shoulder
now this was bleeding was a very very
common treatment endemic you know for
thousands of years it's very few medical
uses today followed by an emetic to
physics and enema with 15 substances
they shaved his head they raised a
blister which is an analogue of
modern-day cupping now you could see
this in the last Olympics Joe sneezing
powder and medics bleeding pitch and
pigeon dung on his feet
a bunch of herbs 40 drops of extract of
human skull
the Bezemer stone aforementioned after
which his Majesty died so a question
that I like to ask is how in spite of
this seemingly obvious fact today that
these things are bogus treatments and
dangerous really to give did they last
for so long and what was the benefit and
why you know why didn't people figure it
out earlier that these things were we're
really bad for you and I think that the
answer relates to the benefits of the
act of care itself and the rituals that
surround it and even some of the the
novelty that surrounds getting this very
strange treatment and so some of those
benefits are benefits that we now think
of as related to the placebo effect and
they're also related to what Frank
Peabody many many years later and then
early 1900s said which is the secret of
caring for the patient is caring for the
patient but now we think of procedures
and biological processes and we have
lost a lot of the idea of care so
obviously a lot of benefits in some
costs as well when we look at things
like responses to surgery higher up on
the y-axis here means a greater response
to surgery across multiple conditions
pained obesity gastric reflux and other
of the
conditions what we see is a treatment
response that sometimes could be quite
large but it wasn't until much later
after many of these treatments were put
into practice and widely used that
people started wondering well is it
really this the surgery I'm doing that's
especially effective and what they
started doing then is comparing the
surgeries to sham surgeries where they
would do let's say a superficial
incision and not complete the whole
surgery and what you see is and many of
those cases people improve substantially
and sometimes they improve as much or
almost as much as with the real
treatment so that suggests that it's not
the the specific surgery itself but the
whole ritual practice of being subjected
to that treatment and a form of care one
of the best known examples is
arthroscopic knee surgery where some
years ago Bruce Mosley who was the team
physician for the Houston Rockets his
sports team started getting curious
about this in the area of knee surgery
and if first reaction was it can't be
this is surgery were talking about right
it's gotta be real it seems like there
are mechanisms but then he did a sham
surgery study and I'll show you a little
clip from the BBC of his study we had a
very elaborate ruse if you will I would
play a video tape on the TV of a real
surgery and while I was watching the TV
I would ask for instruments and pass
things back to forth and carry on
conversation as if it was what I would
really have done if what was happening
on the TV screen was actually going on
during that surgery can you describe
okay now what we're gonna see at this
point is the reporter here talking to a
patient and his wife and he's first
going to describe what his pain was like
before the surgery and then they're
gonna describe life after the surgery
and the important thing here is this is
a sham surgery so they were in the
placebo condition what the pain was like
before the operation terrible oh I
didn't I didn't saying that it could be
in the words in Africa then after the
surgery I was able to do that hey could
we could go dancing
he took me dancing and think it danced
all night I wasn't being a skeptic to a
believer I realized that we were really
onto something there are clearly cases
where we do surgeries and it's as much
or more the patient's feeling about the
surgery that influences the result as
the actual surgery itself so for some
people that can be a substantial benefit
even without an active treatment as a
result many treatments across widely
accepted clinical procedures once
clinical trials are done end up not
being superior to placebo treatments in
randomized controlled trials that
doesn't mean it's not helpful for
anybody but it means overall the
benefits of the treatment are largely
possible in some cases and this is true
for arthroscopic knee surgery for a
vertebroplasty for bone fractures
epidural steroid injections for back
pain and even this is a strange case but
it came out a couple years ago now ah
stents for angina or chest pain which is
what it to heart disease um so these are
all very established treatments and
possible effects can also be large and
confound other kinds of trials and
emerging treatments like gene therapy
for Parkinson's disease which this
particular trial failed spectacularly
also deep brain stimulation for
depression which is something that you
know a lot of us had a lot of hope about
and this paper the trial was stopped
early because even though all the
patients in the study were severely
depressed didn't respond to multiple
treatments I think it's about 23
percent of them responded to deep brain
stimulation and 18% responded to placebo
60 so there was no difference we'll see
both effects are also growing across
time but drug effects or not so the
drugs will see the difference is
shrinking and in certain areas like some
of these areas it's getting harder and
harder to demonstrate a true drug effect
and get drugs to market it's probably
due to the larger placebo response this
isn't just a problem for clinical trials
for many of us it is an opportunity it
really provides a window into the
treatment context and its effects on
health and healing and if you think
about a standard visit to a physician
who gives you an injection let's say
there are many different elements of
this context there is the place itself
there is the interaction with the doctor
both her verbal suggestions when she
says this is going to make you feel
better
I've seen people like you get better and
the nonverbal communication the way she
holds her body the eye gauge the cues in
the voice and and and other cues like
the white coat itself there are also
specific treatment cues the act of
taking that pill the act of getting a
needle puncture or a surgery and of
course there's a rich internal context
which is the change in one's
expectations about recovery one's
beliefs about the future and what now is
going to happen in the future are you
going to live with disability are you
going to die are you going to recover an
associated emotions so lots of fear and
anxiety and which can have in many cases
and for some people very profound
effects on the course of pain and also
in the course of function with things
like motor disorders like Parkinson's
disease what I like to say is that we
put these all these pieces together into
a picture or a schema which is who are
we where are we now in this situation in
the course of illness in the course of
recovery in the course of being cared
for and how do these pieces all fit
together into an overall picture of Who
I am and how the
affects me and it's that schema which is
probably partly conscious and partly
unconscious that has potentially a large
effect on our outcomes so some of these
are conscious like I said some of them
are not conscious and with placebo
treatments we can capture many of these
things some of these effects have behind
us clinically so we've studied this over
the past 15 years by giving people
various kinds of placebo treatments
injections IV pills nasal sprays and
creams and this is a summary of what I
like to call placebo 1.0 this is the
first decade or so of placebo imaging
and this is all what's happening during
pain
so during pain when you get a placebo
analgesic designed to relieve pain there
are
activity decreases in all the areas you
see here in blue so each one of those
spheres comes from a different study and
there are activity increases in the area
as shown in orange and red and the
colors just show you that there are both
causal effects of the placebo where the
the placebo compared to no treatment
causes a reduction in activity or an
increased activity and there are also
correlations with analgesia the amount
of pain relief a person feels in the
same areas and these areas involve
largely speaking decreases in pathways
that process no susceptible or pain
related information and create the
feelings of suffering and aversion and
avoidance surrounding pain including
parts of the thalamus you see here the
somatosensory cortex s2 and posterior
insula and parts of the anterior
cingulate cortex and intermittent slot
and the areas that show increases are
also very interesting because these are
potential mechanisms of of pain relief
so there's increases in the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex which
maintains a lot of information about
contact
and goals in the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex which we've been writing a lot
about we think it's really important for
putting together that schema or that
picture of who you are in this situation
and what how things affect you and
associated subcortical areas which
change value value learning and
autonomic responses and other things so
that's a little snapshot and part of
what placebo research has done for us is
help us to change our views of what pain
and other symptoms are and we used to
think that this is something that
happens to you pain is in your back
alone or in your joints or in your neck
and all of these nociceptive pathways
that you see here in blue carry
information to the brain to various
regions and then the pain just kind of
happens um but what we're learning is
version two that all of these areas that
receive input from the body are also
targeted by so-called top-down circuits
like the medial prefrontal cortex which
can modify activity in every one of
these brain regions and people really
thought about this initially as a pain
inhibition circuit you know the pain off
switch
but what we're learning is it's probably
a lot more complicated than that
instead of just being a very elaborate
off switch for pain if we think of it as
contextualizing when should you feel
pain how much in what situation and so
it contains a set of priors beliefs and
expectations is one way to think about
it and if they're unconscious
predictions that can help shape when we
think we should be feeling pain and when
we shouldn't and so it's sort of example
is you know if you are if you step on a
thorn and it's a very safe context you
know what it is it's clean and sterile
and you know it's not going to damage
your foot it might not be very painful
but if it were in the middle of the
jungle and you know this is something
that might carry disease and you know
that this is potentially deadly then
you're the danger associated with that
pain is much greater and in fact the
brain may just well turn up that
experience and amplify the nociceptive
signal so we think about this as a way
of contextualizing when you should be
feeling what and more broadly instead of
something that just happens to you pain
like other symptoms is an active
inference that your brain makes it's not
just that you have a certain amount of
sensory input it's this decision by your
brain that says hey this is really bad
this is something important for me and
it's important because it predicts a
future outcome future damage future
disability future death things like that
and so they're all active inferences
they're based in part on sensory
evidence coming in from your body but in
part on those priors or prior
information that you have about what you
should be feeling so all symptoms I
believe now are inferred experiences and
of course that's not just the experience
that's important but also the
physiological responses in the body are
driven in the same way and it can also
shape learning which is what you take
away from experiences over time and
that's particularly important so I'm
going to talk about that in a few
minutes but the next I want to turn to
one other idea so a lot of work has been
done over the last century on classical
conditioning and many things can be
classically conditioned including immune
responses which is really fascinating
autonomic responses and other things
that's our real question has been ok so
classical conditioning can work but what
does it matter what something means to
you how you evaluate it consciously and
conceptually so that's been something
we've been pursuing in the lab for a
long time we think that the ventromedial
PFC plays a really important role here
so one way of thinking about this is
that the brain is full of pattern
generators in the ponds there are
visceral pattern generators that will
track changes in the
and in body temperature and if you're
let's say too cold trigger a thermal
regulatory response so on this involves
the coordination of six different things
including your hair standing on end your
blood vessels dilating and some parts of
your body and constricting in others and
your your your feet and hands for
example pushing blood to the core you
can behavioral responses like shivering
and other changes as well all designed
around the same goal so what this part T
nucleus is doing is its detecting an
environmental pattern you to cold
and generating an adaptive response like
coordinating multiple systems so then
the idea is that's a fundamental
function of the brain and as you move up
into the the midbrain and some of these
areas like the Phe you see there's quite
important for pain control what they do
very broadly speaking is their pattern
generators that detect organism
environment interactions I'm being
attacked by a predator I have to fight
or flee I have to do something and
multiple systems are coordinated I've
just eaten something terrible that might
kill me I better curl up in a ball and
you know do various things to prevent a
you know a toxic response and as we move
up then what's the cortex for we have
this massive you know twenty billion or
more in neurons in the cortex alone and
one view of what they do is they're also
pattern generators but now their
conceptual pattern generators they're
for detecting situational schemas like
first date for lunch with a friend or
taking care of a sick child and these
complicated situations that involve the
coordination of many different kinds of
cognition so those kinds might be an
appraisal of the social context how your
body is feeling the interceptive context
and what's happening in your body your
expectations about specific events your
memories for past events and similar
situations in the past and you put them
all together into a picture of where you
are and what the situation is that you
yourself in and so the vmPFC have lots
of evidence that points to this some
things I think are really great are some
nice integrative work by Jeff showing
bomb on the idea that the orbitofrontal
cortex codes has neurons that code for
expectations about specific future
outcomes other work by Dan Schechter
Amanda Buckner on and others on
imagining the future and being able to
form a rich representation of what might
happen to you or what you think will
happen to you another work by Todd heron
and Antonio Rangel and Emily fog on
integrating goals into decision-making
so like if you have a goal to lose
weight then certain foods might seem
less appealing to you if that
information is integrated properly and
that's exactly the kind of work that
shows that information is integrated
between your goals and what the sort of
your other sort of impulses are in the
ventromedial PFC Hilliker plasmon is
another person who's been doing work on
this for years and how your food choices
are modified in this way so one of the
ideas and there are lots of evidence
that sort of points to this but this is
one of the ideas that I found
particularly theoretically interesting
and it involves the vmPFC but I'll get
back to that in a second so first of all
there are cells called grid cells and
hippocampus and surrounding internal
cortex and the idea is that they help
organisms mammals navigate this facial
environment by responding in this sort
of hexagonal grid and what that does is
allows people in rodents and so forth to
form a map of where you are in space in
this directional space and use that to
navigate and when people look for where
those grid-like cells are with human
fMRI the first place they found them was
in the in the hippocampal empirical
cortices
but the next place also is in the
ventromedial PFC so now there was
another really interesting experiment
that was done by alex content and SQ and
Tim Behrens a couple years ago now and
they created a conceptual space in very
brief by showing people these pictures
or they had to learn that the neck of
these little birds can grow in the legs
can grow essentially that forms a
two-dimensional space and what they do
then is have a training task where they
have to learn what the relationships are
between these different combinations and
they have another training task that
easy over there to where you sort of
learn to navigate in conceptual space
and then in long story short they look
for activity in human imaging that looks
like it tracks things in this hexagonal
six Direction pattern that corresponds
to grid cells and the vmPFC is one of
their strongest results so then from
this comes the idea so we extrapolated
from that and thought yes this fits
because it's important for forming a
conceptual map and when you form that
picture of any conceptual situation like
yourself in a doctor's office getting a
treatment this is the kind of operation
that you'll do you'll you'll put these
pieces together into a conceptual map
and that conceptual map will involve
yourself so you can see that here on the
right we have many different sort of
context elements and you have a
representation of yourself and there are
relationships and you put things close
to you essentially and the closer
something is to you in this map then the
more emotional it becomes the more hot
it becomes so things that are close to
you impinge on your survival and
well-being and that's why you generate
emotional responses you'll activate down
on another nervous system your skin will
sweat your pupils will dilate your blood
pressure will go up as these things are
really relevant to you so going back to
what do we think this area is doing we
think that it is not just an on or off
switch for
or emotion but it's providing this rich
multi-dimensional set of prior
expectations based on a representation
of the situation and this is perhaps why
the ventral medial PFC seems to play an
important role in virtually every mental
health disorder that I know of including
chronic pain which is partly a mental
health disorder as well as a physical
disorder I now believe on depression
PTSD anxiety stress-related disorders
and drug abuse as well in substance use
disorders so that's a bit about the
conceptual part and now I'm going to
turn to the learning part and the idea
then is if a placebo treatment can shape
your expectations about what's coming
and where you fit in and what's going to
happen after you get a treatment and
alter those things then it might change
the course of learning and how you
respond to new information so this is
really an interaction between those
conceptual systems that generate
expectations and in other systems in
your brain that are learning what's
valuable what should I avoid what should
I pursue and that's a process that
changes over time right it's it evolves
over time
so here are two curious observations
about placebo effects to me you can ask
well what happens if you just are making
suggestions to people forget about
training them or conditioning them just
just tell them they're gonna get better
and often those effects are very weak so
suggestion alone is not necessarily have
a large large placebo effects what about
conditioning alone just pairing
treatment cues like a needle puncture or
other cues without comes without telling
them anything well surprisingly that
also often has weak effects alone it
seems as though you really need both
things working together so you need the
right kind of
beliefs and expectations initially and
then you need experiences that reinforce
that that say yes I was right that
belief was right if you have those two
things together your brain learns that
this is true so I like to think of this
as I've called this the dance of the
placebos before I like that which is
really a dance between conceptual
processes suggestions expectation your
appraisal of what things mean to you and
your attributions which relates to what
do you think caused you to get better
you know so you have a headache you take
a pill you get better
was it the pill that made you better or
would you have gotten better anyway in
fact in that instance you don't know
because you don't know what would have
happened but you make a causal
attribution and if you believed that it
was the pill that made you better then
you're going to learn that that pill is
good in the future you're gonna take it
more off into the future and it might
even acquire analgesic properties so
it's this dialogue between conceptual
processes and plasticity and neural
circuits that are guided by expert
experience so this is an example of how
placebo treatments can shape the
learning process where we can really see
a learning effect and this was a study
we did a few years ago in Parkinson's
disease patients and while each patient
did is bring in their daily medication
which is generally Sinemet which is
mostly young l-dopa and they dissolve we
dissolved it in a cup of orange juice
and we told them you're gonna drink this
orange juice and then we're gonna scan
you doing a couple of tasks so I'll tell
you about in a second but in fact when
we dissolve that medication in their
orange juice we fooled them we gave them
a different glass of orange juice with a
little bitter substance in it so they
believed that they were taking their
medication but in fact they weren't so
now we could test them off drugged and
on placebo when they believed they were
on their drug and a second group got
the same thing but in a different order
so it's not confounded with time and
then after that we gave everybody the
real orange juice and tested them again
on the active drug so that was another
comparison condition okay and you can
hear me okay right you still with me
there huh I can hit it great okay
pressing on um so what do we test them
on well we tested them on two tasks a
motor task and an opera turning task and
this was the one we focus on in this in
this paper and the idea of the learning
task is it's a it's a task about
learning from reward so you make two
simple choices you choose symbol a or
symbol B make a choice and then you
either win money or you don't win money
and over time you'll learn if you have
reward learning system is intact
you'll learn to choose the the choice
that's rewarded more often and that
happens gradually over time we also have
a punishment learning condition and what
we expect in brief is that people who
have Parkinson's disease have a
deficiency in the reward of learning
system selectively so we expect an
impairment in reward learning systems
and not punishment learning systems and
also some of studies in healthy people
with levodopa as well as in patients
suggest that when you give people a
dopamine replacement to get more
dopamine then they show a selective
benefit for a reward learning task so
what we find is exactly that and what
you see here are curves for learning
across time the black line is off drug
and the green line is on placebo and
what you can see is that they learn
faster they make those optimal choices
faster and the interesting thing is they
also make the choices faster when they
get the actual drug but in this case the
benefit for the placebo is just about as
strong as for the real drug
we don't see the infection running from
punish it uh you know when we look at
the brain we're scanning the brain
during this time now the basic circuit
for this kind of reward learning
involves interactions between the
ventral tegmental area in the midbrain
the nucleus accumbens and the
ventromedial PFC and one take on this is
as follows your expectations about the
value of that reward what you expect
when you choose a given option are
maintained in the vmPFC an Associated
circuits and when you get a reward you
either get the $10 let's say or you
don't then the midbrain dopamine system
in the VTA projecting to the nucleus
accumbens is activated in proportion to
the degree that it's better than
expectations so if you expect it on
average five dollars and you got ten
that's going to drive the dopamine
neurons up so that's this orange pathway
there now how do you calculate
difference from expectations well you
need that representation of expected
value in the vmPFC so it's this
expectation that's compared with what's
coming in that you got and it's that
difference that drives the dopamine
system and drive learning so how do we
find that in the brain in our patients
well the simplest way to do this is to
fit a reinforcement learning model which
makes predictions and every time they
make a choice and every time they get an
outcome about what the expected value of
reward is and what the prediction error
is and then we fit that regressor
to each patient's time series and fMRI
data and look for places where there's a
good fit and what we find when we look
at the correlates of expected value off
drug we don't see much on drug we see
the ventromedial PFC correlating with
value and on placebo we also see that
correlation with value and when we
compare the drug the placebo and know
drugged we see a causal effect of
placebo in the ventromedial PFC so that
means that the signals related to
expected reward value are enhanced we
think now if we look at these curves
across time for placebo real drug and no
drug again we see a benefit for both
placebo and real drug versus no drugs
that are approximately equal okay now
I'm going to come to the last part which
is some of the newer work that we've
been doing and interact integrates ideas
about conceptual value and learning
together so one of my favorite studies
these days is this clinical trial in
this clinical trial they were studying
it's an industry funded trial and the
judge the the company the biotech
company was investigating a gene therapy
treatment for Parkinson's disease that
had shown great effects in papers
published in science and nature and
monkeys and so they started doing this
in humans so that as a v2 neuro treinen
and they inject this into the stratum
dopamine rich areas of human beings and
they're trying to introduce genes that
boost dopamine function and this is what
happens when they get that treatment
what you're seeing is improvements up to
two years so there's a dramatic
improvement in the first six months and
that improvement is maintained for two
years but this trial failed why did it
fail because if you look at what's
happening with the placebo group they
got a sham surgery it's just about as
strong and they stayed better for two
years and this resulted in the drug
company being sold off for parts I mean
they stopped this treatment so it might
never see the light of day so what's
happening how can a placebo affect the
sham operation possibly have benefits
I'm a nerd generated disorder like
Parkinson's for two years I
it's still a mystery but in other
studies of pain we also see cases
several cases where the placebo effect
seems to grow across time and that's
very unusual because often what is
happening is if you give somebody a sham
treatment you're giving them a cue that
says hey expect less pain but without
delivering an actual analgesic and so if
they actually feel more pain than they
expected
they ought to say hey that didn't work
quite as well as I expected it to work
and the placebo effect should go away
over time that's called extinction and
that's one of the best known effects in
learning if you give treatment cues or
other cues without that reinforcement
then the effects should go away but here
sometimes they're growing or at least
are stable over time and how is this
possible well it's possible if there's a
feedback loop where the more pain relief
you expect the more you experience and
the more you experience the more you
expect and this kind of feedback loop
might be created if that experience is
also a teaching signal that changes your
expectations so in a sense what this is
showing you is that you are getting the
pain that you expect and if you really
feel that pain that you expect and
that's that's that's teaching you what
to avoid and what to pursue and what you
know what's going to happen in the
future
then you might get this self-fulfilling
effect so here's a study that we did to
test this and we called it symbolic
conditioning because it's a conditioning
paradigm without any actual
reinforcement so even people saw a
series of shapes like these two shapes
here and after every shape we gave them
a picture of a thermometer and we said
this is this is reflective of low pain
or high pain later but right now it's
just a picture
so people learned conceptually the
association's that one shape meant low
pain one treatment high
without actually getting any primary
reinforcement so a lot of the systems
that might be conditioned in a classical
conditioning we wouldn't expect because
it's really a conceptual effect and we
wanted to ask what what are the possible
effects of this conceptual procedure
where there isn't any standard classical
conditioning and now later they did a
paint a square they got the same shapes
and they were followed by actual painful
heat-safe not not going to damn it to
the skin but so painful and we give them
identical levels of heat for each of the
two types of cues and then we can tell
what are the causal effects of those
cues on the responses to the heat so
we'll always say Green is the low pain
cue bed is the high Pankiw in the
following slides now these cues are
never reinforced so they should cause
extinction we should see that effect if
there is one disappear over time so what
do we see these are pain ratings for the
high pain cues and they are much
stronger than for the low pain cues but
that's a really big effect of course
that's what people tell us but we can
also look at their skin sweating
autonomic responses to those painful
events which are very robust and again
the response is substantially larger for
the high pain than the low pain cues so
that demonstrates a physiological
response that has to be mediated as far
as we know through the brainstem now
this experiment was special in a way and
this was actually I should have updated
the slide here but it was actually just
came out in nature human behavior this
last year so 2018 you can find the paper
on this this paradigm allowed us to do
something a little bit special which is
we have an independent manipulation of
the expectations with these cues and an
independent manipulation of the
experience with painful heat of
different levels and by independently
experimentally manipulating those two
things we can model or estimate what
both of these reciprocal limbs of this
circuit look like so we can model both
the effects of expectation on experience
and vice-versa
and this gives us an empirical
demonstration of a self-fulfilling
prophecy so first of all what are these
effects look like over time well on the
left you see you study one and the right
you see study two a replication in the
scanner and the solid lines are the pain
ratings with high and low Q's and the
dashed lines are expectation ratings so
the first thing you can see is that
effect of the Q's on pain does not go
away over time the reading green lines
are different also people's expectations
do not converge over time they don't go
away so people are still expecting a lot
of pain relief you know with the low Q
and a lot more pain with the high Q in
both studies so they have failed to
extinguish and people's initial
expectations are maintained so the nice
thing then is what we can then do is
model each part of that circuit so here
on the Left what you can see is we've
modeled what's the relationship between
your expectations of pain and the pain
rating on the next trial and you can see
it across five levels or quintiles here
for both Q types there's a very strong
relationship so expectations influence
pain we can also model what are the
effects of pain on your subsequent
expectations and the more opinion you
get then the stronger the more pain you
expect on the next trial for that q type
so that's also a very robust effect so
now we have behavioral evidence for a
self-fulfilling prophecy what about the
vane response well these are all areas
here where the brain responds more
strongly to the same intensity of heat
with a high pain versus the low pain Q a
lot of targets of nociceptive areas and
another story is we've done a lot of
work over the years in developing a more
specific machine learning driven
signature that tracks pain break closely
and doesn't respond to a lot of other
kinds of emotional events like looking
at other people in pain or negative
emotional photos and other things so we
call that the NPS
and we can look at the NPS response and
here what we see is that the NPS
response is significantly higher with
the high pink hues than the low pink
hues and that is significant because
another paper we just published across
20 different studies of a placebo showed
very very tiny effects of placebo
treatments in general on the NPS so we
think that this effect here the way
we've done the conditioning is
substantially stronger than most [ __ ]
bow treatments so that shows us that our
cognitive expectations can have powerful
effects without primary reinforcement or
standard classical conditioning the
experience physiology and brain moved
towards expectations now that's part of
what creates a self-fulfilling prophecy
but it's not enough so what we showed in
our paper and found is that if your
experiences move toward your
expectations to some degree that puts a
damper on learning but it can't create a
self-fulfilling prophecy or a truly self
reinforcing effect if it did you know if
if what you expected or what you what
you felt for example was always exactly
what you expected we would be
hallucinating all the time um so it's
actually not not very likely that we
have those very strong logit ori effects
very frequently so there's a second
mechanism and i'm going to show it to
you in the form of this model we did a
number of computational models that look
at these these effects so i'll show you
so this is one pathway where we have
some noxious input a teaching signal and
a pain response now that teaching signal
the sort of endogenous reinforcement
signal gets compared with the cues at
level two so you've got a cue and that
leads to a pain expectation and when
those two things are compared that
generates a prediction error so if it's
more painful than you expected that
would be a PE and you update the Q value
you update what you expect so that's a
standard learning circuit now
budgetary effect is a pain modulation
effect so if you expect more pain the
reinforced loading signal is enhanced so
that's one short circuit and that's what
I just shown you and that's one
significant effect but there's another
effect here and that effect is a
confirmation bias effect so what we
tested was this idea that not only do we
have pain modulation to some degree we
also have a confirmation bias in
learning so when you get that prediction
there something is more painful than you
expected or less if you expected a lot
of pain and in fact it is very painful
you say yep that pretty much matches my
expectations I'm gonna I'm gonna treat
that data point as valid I'm gonna learn
from that but if you expected a lot of
pain and you get something that dis
confirms that expectation
it doesn't match you say that wasn't
that must have been a fluke so you
discount that data point and you don't
learn and that's true for both high and
low pain cues mm-hmm so and that's an
effect that is not a typical part of the
reinforcement learning literature it's
something that's relatively new and only
a handful of papers that I know if I've
really looked at that um so if that's
true then that's another kind of short
circuit so you believe the the
experiences that match your initial
beliefs and you disbelieve the ones that
don't match your prior beliefs these
simulations actually are things that
just simple simulations that show you
that you really need both effects and so
I won't dwell on that here so here's
some empirical evidence that there are
confirmation bias effects and what you
see here on the y-axis for study ones 32
is the learning rate and the learning
rate is defined as the change in
expectations after you get an experience
that is either greater or lesser than
you expected and it either matches or
doesn't match your prior the Q value
your prior expectations so in both
studies and what I've starred here are
the
cases where the experience matches
inside the expectation like high pain
and you get a new high pain expectation
and it's more painful than expected or a
low pain expectation and it's less
painful than expected in red and green
respectively um then what you can see if
the learning rates are substantially
higher when the experience matched the
expectations and when it didn't in the
farms without stars so those were
significant effects in both studies and
we also confirm that with a whole series
of hierarchical Bayesian models that
really provided convincing evidence to
us that both the pain modulation effect
and the confirmation bias and learning
effect are real and are operative here
um so that's the idea that there are
really two distinct mechanisms one
expectations are shaped by experiences
dampening learning and the second that
we tend to learn from the things that we
already believed in in the first place
so what that means is under the right
conditions initial expectations are
really really important and that can
make the difference between resilience
and recovery versus fear and avoidance
so for example if I'm injured and I just
believe at the start that this could be
really terrible and this means something
terrible for me those expectations may
enhance the pain and I'll pay more
attention to the days when it's worse
and I'll say yes those will confirm that
I really am disabled or injured uh and I
will discount the days when I'm feeling
better I'll say well that was a fluke
and so if I start off with this negative
pattern or negative you know fear and
avoidance expectations in fact my
experiences will confirm that and I will
enter into a cycle of disability in
disuse conversely with positive initial
expectations there's a greater chance
that I will enter a virtuous feedback
cycle of resilience and recovery and
when you look at the clinical literature
on chronic pain
as well as other areas I think it's
clear that your initial fear anxiety
catastrophizing about pain prospectively
predicts how well you're going to do
after surgery so the people for example
you have lots of negative beliefs about
pain about their somatic symptoms and a
lot of depression they don't do as well
after the same surgery as somebody else
who has less fear and avoidance and
anxiety and and greater chances for
recovery and good outcomes after the
surgery so this does play out in in real
life you know so I think one of the
frontiers then is how do we work with
people to develop the right kind of
mindset in approaching health and
illness and surgery and other things
before they've already gone down this
road so to summarize we talked about how
placebos work and about what some of
their long-term impacts might be and we
talked about the idea of symptoms as
emergent properties or inferences that
are based on your prior beliefs combined
with your experience we talked about the
idea that your beliefs determine what
you learn from experience so learning
isn't just something that happens to you
either it interacts with your prior
beliefs and your beliefs guide what you
take away from experience and finally
learning can affect sensory input in
nociception sometimes but more often it
affects interpretations of that input
that then shaped learning and those
interpretations how you understand
what's happened to you and happening to
you that has an impact on your long-term
well-being in trajectory so that has the
potential to create self-reinforcing
cycles
I'm going to end here by thanking my lab
who's been terrific I told you a little
bit about them before a lot of great
people also the funding agencies that
have supported our work on this over the
years we couldn't do it without these
these funding sources especially the NIH
National Institute of Mental Health and
National Institute of drug abuse and and
many others so thank you very much thank
you
make it again okay just unshare it so
that you can okay there we go there you
go thank you very much it's really I'm a
neuroscientist I am looking at basically
the signals and all those things this is
an interesting concept like I'm like I
want like I know about in the real life
experience so I'm I think we don't have
much time in here so I'll ask one
question I have is what you are trying
to like establish kind of like when I go
back and think about it
kind of like alternative medicine right
yeah how do you consider like I feel
like because I don't believe in
alternative medicine but I have I know
some of the people who do very close
friends they always take those
allopathic like what is that some other
like kind of like vegetables this kind
of like other things and they say it is
works for them so have you tried
anything those kind of like medicine
trying to look at those kind of like
literature or anything like that I mean
I you know I think that if you if you
really look at controlled trials of many
alternative medicines there's very
little evidence that they work some of
them are harmful this is a big
controversy still today you know and
people are promoting treatments vitamin
injections and you're but all kinds of
different things right rubbing
cannabidiol oil on your skin all kinds
of things but I will stop there but you
know there's probably very little active
benefit like many I talked about with
surgery and there might be a benefit of
actually engaging positively in the
treatment believing that and having this
sort of watershed moment where before
you weren't taking care of yourself and
now you are and so the rules have
changed for you now you're allowed to
notice those positive experiences and to
engage in a sort of virtuous cycle of
attending and remembering those positive
experiences they actually could be
helpful the thing is that you know we
all have to decide what to believe and I
actually don't believe in
life that it's ethical or the best thing
to take a sham medication which might be
costly which might keep you from using
other treatments that are better and
which might even be harmful you know so
so if there is a benefit of you know
self-healing essentially and engaging in
positive treatments you know there are
probably better options than taking in
pinks I made a lot of money for a fake a
fake drug or something you know so I
think we've got to decide you know what
what to focus on and pursue the things
that actually work but but realizing
that the very act of engaging in
something you know it could be an
exercise program and that have other
benefits too so yeah you know is is it's
probably the better way to go yeah thank
you very much so I think we are out of
time basically smaller than an hour
so I really appreciate it's a very
interesting talk and I really appreciate
you taking time and giving us this
opportunity to for everybody to learn
about your work and learn more about
this placebo effect and all those things
so more of your work yeah thanks if you
have a link to the yeah I'll send you
the link once it is done yeah yeah you
can post it if you want on your website
or anywhere like you're free to do it it
will be on our website for a long time
sure Sangster